I'm marketplace open doors for Elvis
aficionados and bubble wrap
entrepreneurs to become one of the
Internet's most lucrative businesses
this talk from the Commonwealth Club in
San Jose California is 50 minutes
good evening everyone and welcome to
tonight's program of the Commonwealth
Club Silicon Valley brought to you from
the media Center in Palo Alto my name is
Melinda Thomas and I will be your chair
for this evening we'd like to welcome
the listeners of W AM k FM 90.9 in
Kingston New York one of the two hundred
and twenty five stations joining us
nationwide for America's longest-running
radio program it is my pleasure to
introduce award-winning journalist and
author Mike Malone who will introduce
our guest speaker and servers serve as
our moderator for this evening Mike is
the editor of Forbes ASAP the world's
largest business and technology magazine
and a weekly columnist for abcnews.com
he has worked on a number of TV
documentaries including his last project
and book betting at all the technology
entrepreneurs which became a 16 part PBS
series last year
Adam Cohen is a member of the Editorial
Board of the New York Times and author
of the perfect store inside eBay he was
previously chief technology writer for
Time magazine and is the co-author of
American Pharoah Mayor Richard J Daley
his battle for Chicago and the nation he
is a graduate of Harvard College and
Harvard Law School and lives in New York
Adam is the only journalist to be
granted total access into the world of
eBay okay what does Total Access mean
well they actually printed up an
employee ID for me with my name on it
they gave me a conference room the
Vienna conference room for trivia buffs
and I moved in for a few weeks and
people came to me you know I spent my
lifetime as a reporter hunting down
sources so this was quite nice okay is
that one of those things where the you
know you embrace the enemy to keep him
close it's just being a little too close
to oh you're writing about they were
taking a risk and I know that they were
nervous about what I would write they
didn't see it until it came out in an
imprint and I know they were nervous up
until the very end and there's there's
some negative stuff in there there's
quite a bit but I do think overall
they're they're not unhappy with the
book so they hold a potemkin meetings
where you went in and they talked about
doing good for mankind just for you yeah
to write the book probably I don't know
they keep you out of a thing could you
like barge into a board meeting or
something and well there were there was
one group that I wanted to talk to that
I kept getting removed from my schedule
they kept saying oh they're not quite
available and I never did talk to that
group but other than that so were there
any rules stipulated on what you can
attend what you could participate in who
you could talk to um it was really on a
case-by-case basis but they really they
were pretty forthcoming they let me
visit a number of their offices around
the world I went to their Utah back
offices which I think very few people
have been to and is that the great
server farm or um no it's actually the
customer service department and diverse
yeah well no but they said they said you
know do whatever you want watch them
while they answer any emails you want so
of course I said oh could you have this
felt will answer the emails that come in
from users of the adult part of the site
and that was actually a lot of fun so
you were inside three weeks uh two weeks
but then also Berlin London Utah and a
few other places pretty good gig it was
very nice now who'd you talk to
that wasn't with the company anymore
disgruntled ex-employees are always a
good source of information yeah I did I
did talk to a few of them and actually
some of the people that I talked to were
removed from the company during the
course of the project so I their
disgruntlement grew I I talked to many
many people on all sides I also talked
to quote eBay radicals people who hid a
bay out in the community and one woman
who does a newsletter basically every
day attacking eBay saying what it's done
in the last 24 hours that you know she
objects to and and she and actually
another eBay radical who I talked to led
the million auction march in the summer
of 2000 were they they moved two million
auctions off of ebay to Yahoo and Amazon
and other rival auction sites so I
really did try to talk to all sides okay
how about the founders cuz they they can
be pretty hard to get ahold of you know
what started all this off is I was
working for a magazine I they they said
do a story on eBay I didn't know that
much about eBay at the time and my
editor said oh by the way the founder
Pierre Omidyar
has moved to Paris so you'll have to fly
to Paris and have coffee with him for
two days on the Sean's alizée and I
thought okay I'll do that and I did and
I I did meet with Pierre for two days in
a cafe on the Sean's alizée we talked
about eBay how he found it
what his views were about the internet
and commerce and I came back with hours
and hours of tapes and I used them for
the story I wrote but I also realized
this was a very rich subject and I
talked to Pierre more later on but those
hours of tapes from Paris were the heart
of the book really about Jeff Skoll the
co-founder how about Meg Whitman I
talked to Jeff a lot actually shadowed
Jeff round a little bit when I spent
time at eBay went to some meetings with
him Meg Whitman was extremely accessible
and all the way down
Mary Lou song the number three employee
was I think the best source of all she
was there from the very beginning and
she's someone who loves eBay she's also
a little concerned about the direction
it's gone since it went public she was
very forthcoming she was a great source
let's talk about Mary Lou because he
appears to have created the great eBay
myth and a lot of the attention on your
book has centered around your debunking
of the of the great Pez legend so what's
the true story well you know I talked to
Mary Lou at length when I was out at
eBay and she told me in passing it
wasn't something she wanted to make a
big point of but that the Pez myth was a
myth and I thought at the time you know
a year and a half from now when this
book comes out that'll be a very big
deal but let's just kind of sit on it
until then um and the real story was she
was on the number three employee at eBay
she was the first PR person back in 1996
she was trying to get journalists
interested in eBay and no one was no one
believed that strangers would trade with
strangers on the Internet
they didn't believe this auction model
would work and there was so much else
going on that Mary Lou literally could
not break through the clutter um one day
she made up this story she knew Pam who
was then Pierre's fiancee knew that she
did collect Pez dispensers and thought
rather than keep trying to sell
reporters on you know here's this
computer geek who wanted to create the
perfect market why not say he did it for
this romantic reason it worked and the
company embraced the story Pierre went
around telling it Meg when you know Meg
tells the story I was just at their new
Lobby that they've installed at eBay
headquarters and their Pez dispensers
everywhere and I said to them get them
out get them out um although one
executive said to me this weekend that
he was in their Washington office where
they do lobbying and he saw a forum that
they had prepared I guess for Congress
about the company and it had also
mentioned the PEZ dispenser story but
someone had crossed it out so I think so
what's the real truth about the family
of eBay the real truth is much more
prosaic pierre was trying to get in on
an IPO for a video game company in the
summer of 1996 or the spring actually he
had a Charles Schwab account online he
tried to get in on the IPO and rather
naively I think he thought he had a
chance to get you know IPO shares along
with everyone else and he got shut out
he when when his trade cleared it was
for 50% more than the offering price he
realized that insiders had gotten a
better deal and he thought you know we
have this big stock market it's supposed
to be a market but it's completely you
know rigged and he wanted to create a
perfect market where insiders and
outsiders people in the know and out of
the note would all have the same
opportunity so the initial name of the
company was the initial name of the
company was auction web but he had his
own personal website that it was called
eBay he liked the name echo Bay he
actually tried to register echo Bay calm
but echo Bay mines a Canadian mining
company had already registered it for
their homepage he shortened it to eBay
and he created auction web on the eBay
homepage that he already had up and
running but he had a few other weird
things on there including for some
reason Pierre was a great fan of fan
maybe too strong a word but was very
interested in the Ebola virus so he had
created a page about the Ebola virus
about various outbreaks and literally in
the early days people had to click past
this description of you know this
flesh-eating disease in order to I list
an item on eBay now there are offices I
remember in the early days were filled
with giant cutout Star Wars characters
what was that all about
Pierre had many strange interests that
that was one it was also filled with
beach chairs it was a very informal
place literally the early offices were
that furniture was card tables and and
beach chairs and when they had a company
meeting which was about six people they
would all circle their beach chairs and
talk about the direction the company
should take and then they developed
something called the war room which
looked like the inside of an army tent
in the middle of World War two is full
of armies surplus goods and that sort of
thing what was that
absolutely camouflage netting hanging
from the ceiling that was when Amazon
got into the into the auction space and
and they felt that war had been declared
and and Jeff Skoll the the co-founder
decided to really get into war mode they
actually issued dog tags to the
employees and and they regarded it as
war and one of the themes actually that
I came across in the book is we now
think of eBay as being this incredible
success but they were worried at every
stage that in Amazon a Yahoo or an AOL
was going to come in and completely wipe
out the company so they did regard it as
war didn't Yahoo give them an ultimatum
saying either sell out to us or we'll
just run you into the ground and they
did and they did something that was very
hard-edged they actually announced that
they were getting into the personal
auction space a couple weeks before he
BAE's IPO literally when Meg and Pierre
and the rest of the folks were on the
road trying to sell investors on the
company so that was that was a little
bit sharp-edged and i as we know we know
who won that battle we also know at one
point yahoo had a market cap of 95
billion dollars and was gonna buy ebay
and i think he bei was delighted when
its own market cap passed Yahoo's and it
would be the other way around
know there were an awful lot of auction
online sites when eBay got started
they're all gone why did he beige
succeed where the other ones didn't is
there something in their business model
it was a few things it was actually one
quite large well-funded one around in
Labor Day of 1995 when Pierre came up
with eBay it's sort of a little-known
story but it was a site called on sale
which was very well funded very well
publicized the articles about in The
Wall Street Journal and everything they
had the wrong business model though on
sale actually took possession of goods
mainly overstock remaindered items they
had warehouses they held the auctions
they sold it they shipped it out and
that was a bad model because they had a
lot of expenses Pierre's model was
brilliant because it was just a website
connecting buyers and sellers so all
they had to do was keep the website up
and running and take a little cut off of
each option and as Pierre saw the checks
just came in and came in and it was very
hard to compete with that well that
brings us to a question from a member of
the audience and just a paraphrase it
why would anybody participate in an eBay
auction
you're dealing with strangers completely
based on trust going through a website
debt isn't holding the goods isn't
guaranteeing the goods isn't holding the
money it doesn't fit with the
traditional option model that have been
proven over hundreds of years why did
this work at all
well in fact that's what Pierre heard
when he first got the site launched it
was what he heard when he went on a
vision tour of 1997 and tried to get the
national press interested in the site
and again and again that's what people
said but it's kind of like the bumblebee
which they say theoretically shouldn't
be able to fly but does yeah although
all the arguments are that no one would
actually do an option on eBay but boy
they sure do and we saw it again with
eBay Motors when someone at eBay guy
named Simon Rothman proposed that they
start selling cars on the site even
people eBay said okay we understand
beanie babies will understand you know
golf clubs but people are not gonna buy
cars from people in other states that
they've never met you know um but in
fact they're selling a billion dollars
of cars a year on the site right now
it's their biggest item so again
theoretically it shouldn't work by boy
it really does ok so what's with the
logo one of the memorable things about
eBay is that logo yeah and in the early
days when it was auctioned web it was a
really ugly site Marylou who's spoken
about compared the site to a dirty old
newspaper when she saw it and died but
over time they did develop this great
logo and I talked for the book with the
branding guy who thought it up and a lot
of thought went into with the colors the
fact that all the letters aren't lined
up it was supposed to be a little bit
iconoclastic and the branding guy
actually said that when they came up
with this logo that it had a little bit
of the ponytail about it and Pierre of
course had a ponytail when he was
working at eBay so it was it was all
thought out why'd you call the book the
perfect store to use the standard
stereotypical first question I'll use it
right now ok well it really was the
perfect business model and that was what
animated Pierre from the beginning he
wanted to create a store that anyone
could come to on an equal basis anywhere
in the globe so it was that idea of
perfection that I really got out of my
early interviews with Pierre to me that
was what eBay was always about and then
you know doing a little pun on the
perfect storm thought you know seemed
like cobia
clever joke sir now reportedly a number
of companies tried to buy eBay early on
besides Yahoo who else was in the game
well I think you missed one the book is
night night Ritter offered him money to
Oh night root is in there yeah yeah no I
night reader is in there but not I focus
more in the times-mirror story and you
know what was amazing is that along with
all the brilliant decisions they made
some of this was just luck and and one
lucky thing was Pierre and Jeff were
willing to sell eBay for fifty million
dollars two times mirror times mirror
didn't think was worth fifty million
dollars and they you know Pierre and
Jeff were ready to walk away and you
know what's interesting is that not that
long ago times mirror was bought by the
Chicago Tribune company I think at the
time the whole times mirror company was
worth about four billion dollars eBay is
worth like twenty so you know another
huge mistake so times-mirror offered 45
I think knight-ridder offered forty who
else tried to buy him
Amazon invited Meg and and Pierre up to
the Amazon headquarters and talked about
buying them and and Meg told me that you
know Jeff Bezos was saying how you know
Amazon's so great we have all these
warehouses we've all these things you
don't have in Meg and Pierre just came
back and said we don't want all those
warehouses you know we're doing fine
without it so well let's talk about Meg
yeah I mean she is a she probably is the
critical player in the story even more
than the founders how did they find her
and what was her first reaction when she
was approached by these these guys with
this little option company they had a
they had hired a headhunting firm and
Meg's name showed up on a list and Meg
did not want to interview for the job
she did it as a favor to the head
headhunter because he was well known in
Silicon Valley and she thought down the
road he might have a better offer for
her so why why alienate him she had not
really used the internet very much at
all
but when she came out she was very
intrigued by it and one thing that
really interesting came out the game
world right to us
Oh she'd been at Hasbro she'd been at
Disney yeah she she was actually
marketing mr. Potato Head when when they
called in her um and she she was very
impressed with Pierre and everybody but
also really impressed with these profit
margins which were you know above 80%
and just
unlike anything that existed in the
offline world so she was intrigued they
were interviewing a number of people
some more prominent than her but the the
key to the search was actually a word
that Pierre had used from the beginning
which was they were looking for someone
who has a Bayesian and they described to
me how one top executive from an East
Coast firm came out and he flew out
first class and he showed up at eBay
headquarters in a limousine and you know
he'd been headquarters was even then
just a complete dump and they knew this
was not the guy they wanted but Meg was
down-to-earth and completely got it she
was he Bayesian and she was their first
choice and it was an incredible match
did she have any shot going from the
giant corporation to eating lunch at
Jamba Juice next door to you know the
beat-up renob space
eBay headquarters you know she's very
down-to-earth even now so I don't think
that was a concern at all and she works
out of a cubicle rather than an office
but she had a shock that being in the
Internet is just very different from the
entire career she'd had so far for one
thing being in such immediate contact
with her customers she said you know you
do something on eBay and you immediately
get a thousand emails and and things
also happen in such real-time you know
she was under the gun from the minute
she got there but she really likes it
now the interesting thing seems to occur
when Meg Whitman arrives and that is
Pierre starts to fade away yeah
um you know we think of all these tech
legends like you know Bill Gates and
Michael Dell who you know they are the
company and you know you'll have to
carry them out you know for them to
leave but Pierre knew from the beginning
he told Mary Lou actually before you Bay
was anything he said he wanted to do it
for two years and then he and Pam wanted
to move to Paris and Pam was taking
French lessons his game plan was always
to get out and he got out very early and
now he's in Vegas he's in Vegas a little
bit he's in Paris he dabbles a little
bit and you know he does a serious
philanthropy he dabbles a little bit in
some entrepreneurial stuff but you know
he and Pam have a kid and he's having a
great life
now I'm just as intrigued by Jeff's
skull because he does stick around but
he moves consciously out of the
limelight and seems to he prefers to
stay out of the limelight through all
the success through the write-ups and
forbes magazine about the richest
americans and
that absolutely Jeff was very low-key
and part of it also is that once meg was
brought in you can't have two leaders I
mean it was Meg show at that point but
Jeff actually fascinatingly took on a
very different role after meg came in at
the beginning he was the hard core he
was the MBA he was the one who was doing
the business plans he was one making
sure the company worked financially when
May comes in he actually becomes the
champion of the community making sure
that profits aren't the whole thing and
when I was there I actually went to some
meetings with him where they they talked
about how to stay in touch with the
community and he was sort of the
communities are towards the end and now
he's also stepped aside and is doing a
lot of philanthropy okay let's talk
about the community because in many ways
eBay is its community how would you
characterize an eBay er and how
important is the community to the
operations of the firm completely
critical and you know eBay just had its
first ever eBay live in Anaheim this
month and I went to it and there was a
great air of expectation among myself
and the eBay staff because honestly we
all wondered what 50 500 eBay people
would look like and I was reading the
message boards going into it and
literally people were saying you know I
behind my computer all the time I don't
get it out of the house much what would
I wear to this one woman posted that she
wasn't sure if she'd wear shoes so we
were all kind of wondering what the
community would look like and you know
they were great it was a wonderful
gathering and you know when you talk to
the members of the community each one
has just the most mind-blowing story of
what they do on eBay within a half-hour
three people came up to me and I asked
each of them what they did I was asking
everyone what they did one guy sold
license plates on eBay and I said that
sounds like a nice business and he said
no these are these are expensive license
plates they go for a thousand dollars or
more and he he owned license plates from
before from Alaska before Alaska had
roads he sells them on eBay and he's
doing great second woman sells tools on
eBay tiny tools she said only tools they
like a jeweler uses or fry glasses
that's her business and as I said to her
you couldn't open a store where you sold
tiny tools you couldn't get enough foot
traffic but an eBay with 50 million
users you can and the last guy said that
he sold spa equipment parts for for hot
tubs
said you know what was it even mean he
said there's one part of a hot tub that
apparently goes out all the time and he
sells it knew his father-in-law makes
them that's his business so this is the
eBay community and it's you know
startling every time you meet one of
them how many total users are there
right now about 50 million I heard on
the news today that it has the the
greatest number of hits per day and I
guess also the most stickiness of any
site out there very sticky and that was
Pierre's original idea of combining
community with commerce people are
definitely hitting it to log in and
follow their auctions and to bid on
options but these message boards that
Pierre created and that have really
grown over time um people spend a lot of
time the Elvis Presley collectors
meeting with all of us Presley
collectors talking about that time they
saw Elvis and Tupelo Mississippi in 1972
so it's a social as well as a commercial
activity so 50 million users how much
money is exchanging hands per day well
there are 7 million auctions going on at
any given moment so quite a bit now how
about the way that eBay rewards that
community for participating there's a
star system correct and there's also
power sellers exactly what are they well
there's a there is a star system based
on how much feedback you get you get
feedback after transactions power
sellers are people who reached one of
three levels of activity on the site I
know the woman
Karan style who invented the word power
seller it was eBay tries to be
egalitarian in their community and she
rejected names like you know super cell
or she was looking for a word that
denoted that you were active but that
you weren't better than anyone else and
now there are even more levels and they
just announced a titanium level people
who sell 150 thousand dollars a month on
eBay which is just you know
mind-boggling we're gonna get special
privileges because of that so besides
social cachet what what do you get for
being a platinum seller or a super
seller well at chotchkie's you know at
the lower levels you get you get eBay
buddies who will help you with some of
your customer service problems which is
actually very helpful
the titanium level though and I guess
there aren't that many yet they're
actually gonna get to go on annual
retreats with top eBay management so
that's a pretty cool deal no I know a
woman who runs a small and
shop in North Bend Oregon and she
struggled along for years very few cars
going by in a given day and I she was
lucky she's lucky she got one or two of
those cars went on eBay created a
persona called princess glitz and she
actually now uses the antique store
essentially as a storage area for her
eBay work and she's probably quadrupled
her income how many people are there any
estimates how many people out there have
changed their professions to become
full-time eBay sellers there they're
thought to be over a hundred thousand
people right now who just earned their
living on eBay and I met a lot of them
at eBay live but there is I thought you
were gonna get into the flip part of
that which is there is some thought that
eBay may be driving some antique dealers
out of the business through that old
word disintermediation that we heard all
the time during the Internet boom that
everyone thought didn't exist but in
fact it's harder and harder for antique
dealers to prove that they're needed
because right now people can put their
own stuff up on eBay and I I profile in
the book an antique dealer who said that
he had this network of Pickers as
they're called that he developed over 20
years people who found things at garage
sales and brought them to him the dealer
form to sell at his store and he now
finds the Pickers don't need him anymore
he said I've knocked on Pickers doors
people I've worked with for 20 years
they don't open the door they're putting
the stuff up directly on eBay so people
like him this antique dealer have to
continue to find a way to remain
relevant in the eBay age how about
secondary markets companies are being
created or individuals that are building
things specifically for eBay where side
businesses or selling software to help
you become a better like sniping in the
last millisecond before an auction
closes is that business there's a lot of
that there are big companies like on
delay an auction watch that sell
software that help sellers to manage all
their auctions but they're also eBay
went after auction watch hammer and tong
at one point yeah but you know more they
were all these folks we're at eBay live
so eBay is kind of realizing that it's
in their interest it would fight
embracive exactly but there also are
these charming quirky stories of
individuals who have found a way to be
useful to the eBay process one is as you
mentioned sniping software which is
software that allows you to
getting to an auction in the final
seconds and for the book I actually
tracked down the first guy who sold who
created a sniping software this guy
lives in basically a hunting Shack in
Northern California he hunts wild boar
in his spare time he's a high school
graduate he taught himself how to
program for computers off of books he
bought on Amazon he told me it's really
easy and I know it's not really easy he
wrote software to snipe and he also
wallow he's interviewing him actually
looked down and I said oh what are my
feet resting on and he said well
technically those are assault rifles in
the state of California so he was a
quirky fellow but he invented this
software that tens of thousands of
people have bought another woman who's
profiled in the book was selling
tchotchkes on eBay had a little business
going and was trying to cut down on her
cost so she could make the business more
profitable decided instead of buying
bubble wrap that she wrapped it in at
her local store she'd get it directly
from the manufacturer brought the cost
down then one day she decided why not
put the wholesale bubble wrap up on eBay
see if that sells to other eBay sellers
well she now has she had a warehouse she
has a larger warehouse now her husband
quit his job her parents worked for her
a bunch of the neighbors do
she is shipping supply.com selling only
two other eBay sellers selling bubble
wrap she's the bubble wrap lady you know
only on eBay how many people have made a
million have made a million dollars off
of ebay not just selling but including
the original employees the first 75 or
so all made over a million dollars
didn't they I think that's right I think
anyone who had pre IPO stock was
basically somewhere in that they may be
here and Jeff made more than a billion
Meg made some fraction of a billion and
then the first group of first cohort of
employees before the IPO made several
million right as anybody made more than
a million dollars selling on eBay oh I'm
sure they have since there is this
titanium category of people who are
selling 150 thousand dollars a month um
but a lot of that I mean that really
isn't tabulated and and I found honestly
when I talked to eBay sellers they were
a little wary about talking about
exactly how much money they made and I
think there were some IRS issues that I
just tried to avoid was yeah exactly
here's how much I earn and here's how I
spell my name now dad I don't have any
receipts right who is there is there
some sort of asymptotic limit out there
I mean you get this feeling that with so
many millions of items being sold we're
beginning to basically just recycle
America's attics over and over and over
again are they gonna run out of goods
you say that like it's a bad thing but
if we can keep moving things from people
who have gotten tired of them to people
who are excited by them that it's a net
social good yeah absolutely so why would
we complain but also what eBay likes to
point out is although the company has
grown so much still in even its core
areas like coins it only has about one
or two percent of the market they're
looking at the other 98% there's also
the global part of eBay about 21 percent
of its revenues are now overseas and
there are many big markets including
Japan that they have yet to conquer
how about b2b if you're going to notice
more and more manufactured goods
industrial supplies that sort of thing
yes showing up on eBay absolutely b2b
and b2c and yeah that's a huge growth
area and in fact they're working on some
new initiatives and in that but yeah I
mean now we're seeing Sun Microsystems
using eBay as a distribution channel for
twenty thirty thousand dollar servers
and you know that there's any more of
that and also since eBay takes a cut of
each transaction it's very excited about
those sales let's talk about price per
unit if I remember at the very beginning
of eBay someone sold a broken Christmas
ornament for 19 cents and it sort of
became a benchmark for eBay to
constantly move up the per unit price to
go from selling toys and that sort of
thing to selling cars to selling estates
to selling businesses that sort of thing
what is the per unit average price right
now and where does eBay want to go when
I last looked I think it was in the $20
or so range but that that was a while
ago
eBay has this tension they don't want to
lose the small sellers they don't want
to lose the beanie baby people and
that's one reason they had eBay live I
mean that is still the heart and soul of
the community but I was at a meeting
where Meg talked to just a roomful of
like a hundred Wall Street analysts and
their questions were ASP ASP ASP which
is average sales price and they see that
as key to earning so what meg is
definitely done is brought in the big
sellers brought in
Disney's and and the HP's and so forth
but also hold eBay live events because
they don't want to lose the small volume
sellers but what about these big outfits
in the M&A category they've been doing a
lot of acquisitions like Butterfield and
Butterfield yeah need to continue doing
it or they got what they need
you know they've actually one of the
brilliant things they did was actually
be very restrained about M&A at a time
when Amazon was scooping up anything
that ended in dot-com and and you know
paying you know millions and tens of
millions and hundreds of those Cisco -
yeah Cisco - eBay did not do that they
really looked at things that serve their
purpose so one thing they bought was a
small auction site called up for sale
which was actually doing a great job and
also was free and eBay decided this was
not a good competitor to have in the
market for long so they bought it and it
was all this talk about how they were
gonna integrate up for sale into the
business and in fact this site kind of
disappeared so that was one case where
you Bay kind of eliminated a competitor
another brilliant move they did was
buying hef comm half.com was like eBay
but it was fixed price and eBay was so
busy with auctions they never got around
to doing a fixed price alternative and
they realized that once half got started
that it was almost too late to catch up
half was growing like a like a young
eBay started by a young entrepreneur in
Philadelphia and about six months into
half existence eBay bought it and I
think they realized if they didn't buy
it soon you know it would have a major
rival on their hands one things I've
noticed about eBay talking about this
core group of people the true eBay errs
the beanie baby people is that every
time eBay has tried to do something
without their permission all hell's
broken loose they have a mutiny on their
hands absolutely and it's one of the
most fun parts of the eBay story was
getting them to tell me these these
tales of community uprisings I'm about a
week into my visit there someone said
you know about the toaster add instant
don't you and of course you know I I
didn't but I demanded to know and at one
point eBay actually put up an ad with a
toaster with smoke coming out of it a
piece of toast burning and it said you
know is your toaster on the blank come
to you know our our website and it was
for a major hardware store get a new
toaster well
toaster selling community on eBay and
they were there got up in arms and they
said this is the first time that eBay
was actually taking ads for people who
were competing with the community people
who were selling on the site and it
actually was something that the whole
community rallied around because
everyone saw their own business
eventually being competed with and eBay
back down on on the toaster head they
took it down and Meg made a commitment
she said we're not going to compete with
our community again in the future now
there was a period a couple three years
back where one year eBay seemed to go
through every possible disaster the
servers went down they were hacked
I think the SEC was looking into them
they raised their prices or they changed
their price structure and the eBay errs
mutiny
what happened did they just lose track
of where they were well it's really been
a process of trial by error and also um
you know with an Internet company things
just happen that are beyond your control
I mean the darkest day in eBay's history
of course was the summer of 1999 when
the the website went down for 22 hours
and as as Meg and Pierre told me they
actually had a conversation during the
time where they realized it might never
come up again eBay might not have ever
been able to restore itself of course
they could have started up again but all
that data would have been lost and that
was a very dark hour um and a lot of
wood eBay has done since then has been
reacting to that they've built in
redundancy maynard webb who they brought
in to do their technology was just
promoted i actually just today the chief
operating officer they've really tried
to learn from the mistakes no they when
they began they spoke of not Palouse
policing the site they wanted to have it
be free in an open market and you know
Pierre's vision of everybody playing and
then people started selling body parts
and and things like that at what point
did they decide that maybe we ought to
police this thing a little bit well it's
been a constant struggle between the
libertarian instinct and a few things
one is legal concerns um they banned
guns from the site another community up
for one that they did not back down on
they banned guns from the site shortly
after a Brooklyn jury came in with a
verdict against gun manufacturers for
negligent marketing and eBay
realize we could be sued if a gun is
bought on eBay and used in a crime so
they've done things like that throughout
the course of their history but also you
know some of it has been much more
haphazard they did a whole evaluation of
their adult site and they made some new
rules when they got a complaint from a
grandmother who was searching for a doll
for her granddaughter and was just
amazed what the word that was relatable
one yeah she know about these dolls so I
really tried to adapt over time
the company also experienced as much as
fast of a run up as any company in
history I would imagine I think the
stock originally opened at what twelve
dollars and if you include at the peak
of the boom including all the splits
that same same share stock was worth
about eight hundred and fifty dollars
companies that grow that fast oftentimes
tear themselves to pieces how did he
baekje from doing that well yeah when I
first met Pierre which was in the fall
of 1999 he was 32 years old and he was
worth four billion dollars and you know
it's just cut off his ponytail hey he
did he was he was kind of dressed up for
the occasion for the interview that was
nice of him um but yeah I mean part of
it is just that Pierre and Jeff are
truly such down-to-earth people they
continue to drive their old beat-up cars
not to make a statement but because
that's the kind of people they were and
eBay spent a lot of time telling the
employees you know remaini days in don't
you know go bragging about how much
money you've made and and actually the
day of the IPO they told people that you
can check the stock price like once or
twice but that's it so there was all
this whispering with people trying to
ask each other what the stock was up to
but they've really tried to keep it has
a very modest place and they changed it
did change and they've begun Mary as
Mary Lou told you get changed it went
from beat-up old vega's in the parking
lot to Porsches and you know that sort
of thing and the old-timers will tell
you part of what change is at a
different kind of employee came many
more envy MBAs that the people were
there in the early days were not really
qualified for their jobs literally one
of the early employees I talked to was
hired by eBay because she was she was a
hairdresser she was cutting someone's
hair and and her client said oh you
should really drop a resume off at eBay
and they were
so desperate for people that they they
hired her on the spot but now it is MBAs
it's people who know about eBay stock
growth it's folks who are you know
probably more there for the money and
and also it's just so much larger I mean
I was amazed going back there to
headquarters today how many of the
employees I talked to you really don't
have a sense of Pierre they have no idea
who Mary Lou was you know it's it was
sort of sad well you could on one hand
you could say that's inevitable for any
great successful company but on the
other hand that's also oftentimes the
beginning of the end yes it could be and
I think with a different CEO it could be
a problem but Meg really spent a lot of
time with Pierre I know she was very
concerned about kind of picking up the
DNA and I really think she does have the
Bayesian value values and you know this
eBay live event was an example of that
of really she was down there with the
community really tight and I don't mean
down in the pejorative way but she
really is in touch with the users and it
was kind of charming to see that they
treated her like a rock star and they
had printed up little trading cards with
it with eBay employees on them and there
were Meg Whitman cards and literally
eBay users were running after Meg you
know like like a rockstar asking for to
autograph their cards um but you know
she's really she is in touch with me so
when does she get bored and move on boy
that's a big question oh I mean I always
wonder you know if you have about a
billion dollars why why do you work for
you know is there is there a line of
succession behind her right there's
nobody that has come out into the
limelight there there was there was
someone who had been number two who
seemed like he might take over but he's
actually been been he was that that was
Brian sweet and he's actually no longer
number two Maynard was just made number
two Maynard Webb I don't know if he's a
successor but I don't think Meg shows
any signs of leaving whereas Gary Benji
R who was the chief financial officer a
brilliant part of the original company
spent the last year traveling around the
world with his family um you know that's
another way you can live your life you
get a question from the audience you
seem to see Steve Wesley as a turning
point he is not listed as an informant
in form it's interesting term was he
cooperative Oh Steve was a great
informant I I don't know if I didn't
list him but no Steve was a great
informative
they told me all kinds of good stuff um
he was a complete turning point in the
company when he came in he brought he
was a Stanford MBA he put two of his MBA
students with him and they were the
first real business people at eBay and
it was not without tension I mean one of
the things that people sort of whispered
to me when I was there as they said you
know he came in out he came in I guess
September of 1997 and they said you know
we dressed up as them for Halloween we
all like wore blue blazers and you know
and nice shirts and you know because
they were so alien when they got there
but they did change the culture but they
also really built the company they were
crucial to eBay being what it is today
I'm curious so there's a rule around
here that when a company builds a
corporate headquarters short the stock
and eBay seems to have always escaped
doing that they're still in the kind of
warren executive office complex that
they started out in oh yeah if you're
worried about the stock in that regard
they have really ugly offices they had
an opportunity early on to buy some
offices that Apple had built in and then
couldn't move into they turned it down
and I was shocked I mean one thing
that's been true up until this year is
they wouldn't even pay for an employee
cafeteria to the point that their
employees have to walk across a very
busy street Hamilton Avenue at lunch
time with like cars whizzing by to buy
their lunches at Whole Foods and I did
see when I was there today that they
have this little you know very little I
baked a face oh they're saving their
employees lives maybe that's a good
investment we have another question from
the audience
have you used eBay what have you bought
sold and how would you characterize the
experience um I've only bought I haven't
sold but it's been great
this watch a Swiss Army watch that I
really wanted to get and I actually was
gonna buy it
Bloomingdale's can I say that for $240 I
got it online new on eBay for 4050
dollars and I've had it for a year and a
half it's great I completely recommend
the experience these eyeglasses frames
they were discontinued when I went to my
optometrist to get new glasses he said
they don't make them anymore I went on
eBay
there was an optometrist in Florida who
had a cache of them and I got them for
less than half price and then my
favorite item I got is I got this little
Turkish rug
was hand-woven in Iran in the early
1960s that has a likeness of President
John F Kennedy was slightly
middle-eastern features and only on eBay
so what's the most expensive item e but
the most expensive item I bought is that
got in a really brutal bidding war for
um there was a guy in it there is a guy
named John fryer he's a fine art student
in Iowa he put his entire life up for
sale on eBay he had a party at his
apartment he invited all of his friends
they labeled everything he had and he
sold everything and I of course wanted
to have something just to be part of the
experience for the book I bought a
tropical fish shirt for more than it was
worth but what came with the experience
is that John actually then went around
the country visiting his items we had
lunch in New York and we had this
completely surreal lunch where I was
interviewing him for the book and he's
in the book but he was interviewing me
for his book and and now there's a
picture of me up on his website and then
I was saying how weird this was but then
he also had to run to it to leave to go
to Grand Central Station where he was
meeting a woman who had bought a
five-pound bag of sugar from his kitchen
and he was taking a photograph of her
with the sugar so I thought that was a
good investment well let's talk about
good investments one claim has been made
is you really don't get that many
bargains on eBay that by the time the
bidding is complete on anything that's
worth buying it's pretty well equal to
or exceeded the retail price what I love
about eBay is that the the buyers tell
me constantly things are so expensive
you now suddenly you're you're you're
buying things for the most the highest
price that anyone in the world is
willing to pay for it and and they
complain you know one woman I quote in
the book says you know in the old days
you go to a thrift store there'd be a
little bin in the corner with 8-track
tapes and it would say a quarter and she
had a friend who bought an 8-track tape
on eBay for 258 dollars so she says it's
just completely destroyed buying but
sellers of course all say oh my god you
know it's driven prices down you know
you can't get good prices anymore and in
fact what you're seeing is the
perfection of the of the market junk is
being bid down as people empty out their
attics but the truly rare items are
getting more than they've ever gotten
before and that sort of what pricing
should be so the days of the Duesenberg
in the garage
in the barn in Enid Oklahoma or over
because of eBay those things are being
pulled out there being located and also
this sort of you know the serendipitous
you wander into the antique store and
you see something that no one else has
seen there's a story in the book about
the antique pickle jar a guy had a
pickle jar he didn't know what it was
worth he put it up on eBay and of course
the pickle jar collecting community and
you didn't know there was one they found
it and they began emailing him madly
saying is that in amber nine 1856
whatever and within two days they were
actually showing up at his house and
visiting the pickle jar and inspecting
it it was in fact amber it was number
eight not number six or number ten it
was the rarest pickle jar in existence
and it went for forty four thousand
dollars um is there there seems to be
some sort of synergistic relationship
between Antiques Roadshow and eBay and
I've noticed now that eBay is doing some
sponsorships with Antiques Roadshow what
kind of connection is that I mean we
just like is this the zeitgeist now
we're all just obsessed with finding old
cheap stuff and buying and selling it
there's a passion for collecting that
when I went into this book I thought by
the way in addition to you know figuring
out what eBay was all about I was gonna
figure out what what collecting was
about I must say I failed it that
miserably but I spent a memorable
weekend one August in Kansas City with
people who collect antique clothing
irons they also collect antique clothing
I sprinkle bottles that you sprinkle
water on the shirt when and also the
third part of the antique clothing iron
collecting Trinity is anything with the
Flatiron Building in Manhattan on it
they are incredibly passionate about
this they spend $15,000 and more for
antique clothing irons on eBay they're
incredibly proud of their collections I
have no idea why they do it for the same
reason you buy your glasses on ebay now
eBay has transformed slowly almost
collation lead over the last six years
from being a sight there was very plain
vanila sight very straightforward
listings driven by narrative almost
entirely narrative driven sight
increasingly in the last
two or three years we've seen more and
more imagery being put on the site and
people selling cars now sometimes will
refer you to a link that will take you
over and show you 200 photographs so
their Ferrari Dino or whatever it is
they're selling is this the direction
eBay goes is this where the future is
absolutely and one of the most to me
amazing stories that I uncovered for my
book was I found out a lot of people
they started talking in the community
said do you know about Pongo and Pongo
turned out to be this early eBay
celebrity who she made her name she was
the first person to help people post
little photos on on their auctions back
in 1996 when no one knew had to do this
and no one had a digital camera
Pongo ended up being fascinating because
she lives in Alaska and she actually is
someone who had amnesia for ten years
and had a previous identity as a
reporter in Seattle and her family lost
track of her for ten years and wrote her
off as dead and she said riah merged on
eBay and it was you know completely an
amazing story and anyway it's in the
book but but um but Pongo was there in
the trenches when no one you had it even
put up that little you know
black-and-white photo now yes all the
things are describing their true and
what I envision is as more people at
broadband as the Internet becomes you
know bigger and faster which you will I
imagine a virtual experience where
you'll almost be able to walk in and you
know pick up that laws and turn it
around and that's all to the good more
information but there's a legacy issue
involved in that too and that is five
years from now when broadband does get
out there and you can go out and start
the car and listen to the motor there's
still gonna be this large contingent of
eBay errs at 56k how is eBay gonna drag
these people along they're completely
attuned to that in fact today when I was
at eBay just chatting with employees you
know you keep learning things and you
wish you hadn't finished the book cuz
you want to put them in and I talked to
the guy I talked to one guy I was asking
over what do you do at eBay and and he
said he designs the site and I said well
what's happening with that and he said
well he said shush
but anyway I'm gonna say uh then he had
just finished they a new virtually no
exactly just the two of us don't tell
anyone but a new version of the website
that is actually gonna have slightly
fewer graphics and it's specifically for
those 56k people so it's they're
actually simplifying right now
completely attuned to that base do you
see does Meg see eBay as a fully
broadband virtual experience in the
years to come is that are they are they
installing the servers the real-time
servers that do that stuff right now I
haven't heard that but I figure if I
keep saying it everywhere I go and I
sort of made it up myself that maybe
they'll do it they've I feel like done
other things that I've spoken about so
anyway I hope you're listening Meg
what's the most expensive item ever sold
on eBay
last I heard it was a Gulfstream jet
that was bought by I think a commuter
airline in Africa for 4.3 million
dollars but they don't always keep such
careful track of g4 g5 we know the
difference the Silicon Valley
yeah we don't in Manhattan itself what
about the role of celebrities you need a
success um Rosie O'Donnell absolutely
grows early on Gloria Vanderbilt was on
the site um I think it's helped and
Rosie's been a big booster but I
actually think you know Oprah can make a
book there there are things that
celebrities really are influential and I
think eBay just was a force of its own
one of the questions is have you talked
maybe sure have you shown the book to
Pierre Meg and Jeff and if they read it
and they have comments um Meg I know
read the galleys
I sent when he sent the galleys which is
the early version of the book to the
folks at eBay they immediately gave it
to Meg who told me that she was going
into a meeting I hope it wasn't an
important meeting but she said she just
read the galleys throughout the entire
meeting and and was it basically done
with the book when it was over that was
pretty impressive she said she really
liked it a lot and and I someone told me
today that she's been going around eBay
saying he's told all of our secrets but
uh but she she likes it and I actually
just autographed a book for her today
Pierre sent me a note we auctioned off a
copy of the book on eBay with all of
their signatures for the eBay Foundation
for charity and Pierre sent me a note
along when he signed it and sent it back
to me saying that he hadn't read it yet
so I thought gosh there's so much about
you Pierre
get on get on the ball you know when
CEOs and founders say they haven't read
it yet they've read it they've read it
okay yeah-oh word would have been nice
beer uh-huh make some predictions
where's eBay at five years
you know my sense is given the history
of this town that the greatest
competitive threats aren't from your
competitors they're from the unexpected
new technology coming in over the pole
that catches you blindsided like desktop
publishing did to publishing pcs to many
computers that sort of thing absolutely
I think that eBay is really keeping its
eyes you know peeled in all directions
so I don't see them being blindsided um
I think the growth will continue to be
huge think about they've grown revenues
125 percent in the last year and that's
a year with not only the dot-com bust
but also a huge recession I mean they
they really are an amazing force much
more overseas and as I say I think more
of this virtual experience like
racetracks and movie theaters does eBay
do better during a recession yeah
meg has been going around saying that
she thinks it may be counter cyclical
because people need to empty their their
attics out when they need money so go
out 5 years how big are they
users Wow
I think I think we're gonna hit 100
million before around then what about
sales whether it is Meg had said within
five years and this was two years ago
three billion dollars so I mean five
billion I don't know I this guy is the
limit I'd say at what point do they get
limited by the web itself they've done a
good job of keep you know in the early
days the site kept crashing it was they
had all these technological problems
they were up I think 99.5% of the time
last year so I don't think that's gonna
be the problem there are scalability
issues I guess if if everyone in the
world is on it you know what do you do
when the winning you know bidder and
your auction lives in Lahore Pakistan
and you know you're not I don't know I
mean that's more of a leap of faith
certainly than selling to Muncie Indiana
but I think these are solvable problems
what about you know there are major
questions though about currency
transactions and trading and that sort
of thing how is eBay involved in this at
all if you buy something from Kuala
Lumpur and you got a this big currency
problem they're not helping you are they
well the seller determines what currency
they'll take and most sellers just take
dollars and also eBay is creating more
and more of these country-specific sites
so a lot of people in Britain are buying
on the British site which is in pound
sterling or
Deutsch marks so there is that option
but anyone in the world is free to to
work on ebay.com as well any other fears
for eBay what can go wrong with this
model I mean you call it the perfect
store but he but Sears was the perfect
store at one point so was Montgomery
Ward's and it's gone what happens to
eBay well be the worst thing they're
petrified all the time you know
certainly there are still big players
who could do them damage um one scenario
is Microsoft could I mean Microsoft
tried to get it in on auctions but
suppose they built something into
Windows which as we know they force
everyone to use everything they want on
Windows and suddenly you you know in
order to have your computer operate you
have to place bids on their auctions um
there's always you know always potential
threats but I really think he Bay's up
to the challenge one more question and
that is Microsoft didn't have any
competitors left either but they forgot
one which was the United States
government at one point a bay was being
investigated under antitrust is that a
danger they own the marketplace
it's lately it's always a danger but the
thing to remember about antitrust law is
it it's not illegal to have a monopoly
not that they do and remember Amazon and
Yahoo big internet players are both in
the space not illegal to have monopolies
illegal to behave anti-competitive lis
and other than that up for sale
purchased a long time ago I haven't seen
any signs of it would you buy you Bay
stuff I can't I cover them but I but the
books done you're here you're so
conflicted it wouldn't matter anyway
1999 I had this idea to write a book I
should have just bought the stock and
not written the book right so so what he
worked on now I just started a new job
at the New York Times and they sort of
told me not to take on any new projects
so I'm following orders once this tour
is over it's back to the great land to
the grind exactly terrific thank you
very much thank you
hope you all enjoyed tonight's program
of the Commonwealth Club Silicon Valley
again we'd like to thank Adam Cohen
author of the perfect store inside eBay
Mike Malone editor of Forbes ASAP in to
our audience here in Palo Alto and those
of you at joining us at home and now
this meeting of the Commonwealth Club
Silicon Valley part of the nation's
largest and oldest public affairs forum
is adjourned
Adam Cohen is the former chief
technology writer for Time magazine and
is currently an editorial board member
of the New York Times the perfect store
inside eBay is published by Little Brown
and company on the web at TW bookmark
com